i really want to start with
congratulations on the movie um it is
hard to get any movie made i would
imagine making this movie was a
tremendous challenge after watching it
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of films um is
there anything that you think might
surprise people to learn about the
actual making of this movie what i feel
like anybody would be surprised at is
how hard it was to do it to just get it
on the screen because i think that
people just think of you have the
conception of the movie and then you see
it on the screen everything in between
no one talks about those battles in the
room the hustling for your worth the
fighting for the actors the fighting for
the budget the fighting for the hair
choices of the hair choices of you know
wardrobes choices of
i don't know even you know the scars
everything is a fight you know and i
think that is what would surprise people
the most because i i think that people
have an idea that is easier than what it
is
that's what i would say
yeah from my part um it would be the
stunts
i
during my audition process i had to go
through a physical
test for the stand coordinator to
determine whether i'd be able to do my
own stunts or not because we had to do
our own stunts in the project
very welcome
great however i
i'm afraid of heights
and i had two wire sequences um but
you know you do it and because we're
doing it ourselves we have to we're not
stunt devils it doesn't come naturally
to us you know there's a you do it over
and over again got to a point where i
told danny i was like you remember that
i'm afraid of heights right you know
stuff like that but yeah and we had to
swim
yes the test dude doesn't mean
everything i was like i'm gonna drown
that's what was gonna happen
i definitely want to know after making
this do you have like new respect for
what liam neeson does in the take in
movies absolutely all the action stars
absolutely yeah absolutely but i had
respect for what he was doing before
because not only the action sequences
but i have to say his age
you know you're not you know he he's not
coming to set you know as a 20 something
year old where your body rejuvenates
easier
you know but um
so yeah now that you but that's with
anything once you actually do anything
you see the fantasy of it and the
reality of it
um i thought gina did such a great job
with the action set pieces in this movie
and both of you did such a great job um
can you sort of talk about what it's you
mentioned a little bit about the
challenges of um of what it takes to do
these things but like are you ever doing
like 20 takes of some of these things
can you sort of talk about like the
behind the scenes of filming one of the
sequences
um i'll talk
the recruits have an obstacle course you
know to prove their worth um in the film
and there's the thorn sequence and there
are multiple angles that they want to
get multiple people they want to cover
um
and like i even have like the scar is
from the thorn running through the
phones and that day because we had
limited time
to shoot
everything right and so even with the
something like that yeah we have b unit
covering it but it's also like we're
mindful of time but we don't want to
show change the sequence itself and i
bust my name
um on the day we're shooting the
obstacle course but then again we're
doing our own stunts and when you see
naui
doing this as she went towards that
platform that's because my knee was
buzzed and i still have to
run and jump onto that platform you know
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah i don't
know if you want to add anything well i
had to flip
a man in the village raid scene when we
come out of the grass and then i battle
this one guy
and flip him over
and they said cut didn't work
and i was like wait wait wait wait wait
what would the bird would buy you know
and then i think i may have done that 20
times
and i'm saying 20 times where you're
literally flipping a 200-pound man over
your
your back and your hip
and i i thought to myself there were
times when i said okay
somebody else is gonna have to do this
roll well they're gonna have to call in
another actress like we're gonna have to
we're gonna have sony sony studios for
more money
and that's gonna have to be because it
really we were like a goji um in the
term in terms of having battle scars
yeah
yeah yeah
and we were very very safe now but it's
just always safe but there was no i
oh my god i mean so many scrapes i had i
had a lot of scrapes it really shows in
the movie thank you so much for your
time thank you
you